ميسي يضيف كاس العالم لقائمه انجازاته فهل
حسن بذلك جدل الافضل على مر العصور والمسك
استفتن الناس على مصيره في رئاسه تويتر
والجماهير قالت كلمتها الصادمه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ومع تحقيق ميسي للقب كاس العالم طلع
المعسكر المسيوغال خلاص ميسي اثبت انه
تايمز مصطلح رياضي معناها الافضل على مر
العصور وهذا لقب في معسكرين في العالم
بيتخانقوا عليه اكيد طبعا عرفته المعسكر
الثانيين رونالدو فاللاعبين يعني اساطير
في اللعبه وعنده تاريخ ارقام واحصائيات
طويله جدا لكن الاثنين كان ناقصهم كاس
العالم ميسي رونالدو
على مر العصور احنا سالنا مجموعه من
الصحفيين والمحللين الرياضيين وهذه كانت
اجاباتتهم
يقدر يعمله انا شايفه ان هو ما فيش حد
ثاني هيعرف يعمل اللي هو قادر يعمله
بالطريقه دي لان هو الموجبه اللي عنده
يعني رونالدو جسمه قوي جسمه يعني حاجه
فازه القدرات اللي عنده فيزك لي حاجه
فازقه مسي- بجسمه صغير بالسكين والثالث
الموهبه اللي هو اللي اتولد بها بيعمل
حاجات مرعبه ان هو يبقى عنده 35 سنه ويقدر
يحلم بقاله سنين طويله جدا بيحاول يعمله
همم حاجه همم تتسجل له يعني التاريخ لو
لازم اختار هاقول ان مثلا هو اعظم لاعب في
التاريخ كسب كل حاجه ممكن يكسبها في
الكوره من دوري في اسبانيا الى دوري
الابطال دوري الانديه كاس العالم الانديه
كاس العالم
كاس العالم ممكن بعد يقول اه ممكن بعد
يقول لا بالنسبه اه مش بس عشان هو كاس
العالم اللقب الوحيد اللي كان فاضل له
عشان يختب اللعبه زي ما الناس بتقول لكن
بالنسبه لي لان ميسي ما فيش لاعب في
العالم حاليا بيتفوق عليه في الارقام او
البطولات الجماعيه او البطولات الفرديه او
الارقام الشخصيه الفرديه والجماعيه في
الفتره الاخيره
في المستقبل همم لانه ببساطه في نقاش
مماثل لم يتم حسمه عبر 10 سنوات الماضيه
بمرين مارادونا وبيليه ومين فيهم همم افضل
طبيعي انه همم يبقى النقاش ده موجود بسبب
الشعبيه الجارفه والنتائج المذهله
والارقام المذهله للنجمين همم وفي النهايه
هو لقب معنا قوي الجماهير بتمنحه للعب
المفضل بتاعها اللي بتحبه ان هو الافضل
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
من الافضل
الابطال القوميين التاريخيين صحه التسميه
مثل مارادونا وبيليه وهم الاشهر طبعا
اصبح معهم ومشجعوه يعني يطلقون هذه
التسميه وهم مرتاحه لكن الجدل لن يحسب
ان سالت عن رايك انا ارى ميسي هو الافضل
عبر التاريخ
ويستحق ان يكون الافضل الوجود في زمن صعب
في كره القدم ليس مثل زمن مارادونا
الارجنتين اوتوماتيك لي يعني مرادف لها هو
ميسي هذا اللاعب طبعا الاسطوره اللي امس
كان ناقص سلسله طويله من انجازاته فخلال
مسيره مستمره اكثر من 30 سنه ميسي فاز ب
37 لقب مع انديته برشلونه وباريس سان
جيرمان وميسيتهوش به الكره الذهبيه سبع
مرات اكثر من اي لاعب اخر وفاز بالحذاء
الذهبي لافضل هداف في اوروبا 6 مرات ومع
المنتخب فاز بكوبا امريكا وفاز معه كمان
من ميداليه ذهبيه اولمبيه هذا غير سلسله
طويله من الارقام القياسيه في التهديف
والاحصائيات المذهله كل هذه الانجازات كان
ناقصها بس كاس العالم وهذا حقق ميسي امس
ومع تسمى كمال افضل لاعب في البطوله ومن
وقتها والاحتفالات شغاله طبعا المقارنات
مع الاسطوره مارادونا اللي كان اخر من جاب
اللقب للارجنتين من 36 سنه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في وقت المختصين والمحللين والصحافيين
منهم اللي احتاروا منهم اللي قال صعب
اختزال اللقب في شخص واحد واخرين شافوا
الموضوع بيعتمد على كثير اشياء يبدو ان
الجمهور العام رايك كان اكثر وضوحا ليه
بقول كده لانه نحن عملنا تجربه صغيره
وسالناكم في استفتاء على حسابنا على تويتر
لو برايكم بس خلاص كده الافضل الان صار
على مر العصور والنتيجه كانت بفارق مو
بسيط اكثر من 66% شايفين انه نعم هو
الافضل عبر العصور والباقي شايفين انه لا
وبمناسبه الحديث عن نهائي كاس العالم امس
في المباراه كانت مليانه بالمشاهير من
مختلف المجالات شفنا رؤساء الدول مثل
ماكرون اللي منتخب بلاده كان بينافس على
اللقب وشفنا اللاعبين كره
ابراهيموفيتش وبكم وكمان شفنا الرياضيين
مثل نوفاكوفيتش
شفنا كمان المباراه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هو بمناسبه الحديث عن ماسك فاكيد يعني
حضوره لكاس العالم ما هو الخبر الوحيد
اللي يخصه صحيح هو في الدوحه كان بيتفرج
على المباراه في تويتر
سبورت او دعم تويتر اعلن عن سياسه جديده
اشعلت غضب على جدل على انتقادات على اللي
تبغوه يعني سياسه عنوانها الترويج للمنصات
الاخرى على تويتر فالشركه جالس في تغريده
انه بتقدر طبعا او بتقدر طبعا انه في كثير
مستخدمين مشتركين بمناصات اجتماعيه اخرى
لكن نحن نشر اي محتوى في روابط او اسماء
مستخدمين للمنصات الاخرى مثل فيسبوك او
انستغرام او تروس سوشل وغيرها عموما كل
منصات معروف انه في الجولدنز حقتها بتقلل
ظهور اي محتوى في ترويج لمنصات اخرى لكن
منع نهائي بهذا الشكل ما في وهذا كان سبب
موجه انتقادات وجدل وقادها مؤسس تويتر
ورئيس الشركه السابق جاك دورسي اللي رد
على التغريده بكلمه واحده وقال واي ليه
وغير جاءت ملايين احتجوا ينتقدوا هذا
الشيء هذا للتراجع سريع في حساب تويتر حذف
التغريده والبيان وماسك وضح في حساب وهو
يرد على سؤال احدهم وقال انه راح يصير
تعديل على السياسه والحضر راح يكون
للحسابات اللي راح تخصص بشكل اساسي ووحيد
كل يعني تغريدات هذه الترويج لمنافسين غرد
ماسك كمان وقال انه من الان فصاعدا اي
تغيير على سياسه رئيسيه راح يوضع للتصويت
قبل اقراره وقال بعتذر وما راح يصير كده
ثاني ويبدا انه ماسك ما كذب خبر وخصوص
الاستطلاعات قبل اي قرار مهم وهذه المره
الاستطلاع كان الاستفتاء على مصيره يعني
قرار في غايه الاهميه وهذا الشيء كان
مفاجاه غير متوقعه فنشر استطلاع للراي طلب
من متابعينه ويصوتوا على انه يبقى في
تويتر رئيس او لا واكد ووعد الجميع انه
راح يلتزم بنتيجه الاستطلاع ايش ما كانت
وبالفعل فوق 17 مليون شخص صوته على
الاستطلاع خلال ساعات وكانت النتيجه
قدامكم اكثر من 57% صوتوه نعم تنحى و42%
ونصف صوته لا خليك ماسك بعد ما نشر
استطلاع غير رساله شوفوها يعني رساله
مبطنه على المصوتين واستخدم مقوله
انجليزيه شهيره ترجمتها انه تكون حذرا مما
تتمنى لانه من الممكن انه تحصل عليه او
يتحقق لك تغريده ثانيه حملت رساله ثانيه
مبطنه كمان فغرد وقال لنفسهم في السلطه
والقوه هم اقل ناس بيستاهلوها يعني صواريخ
يمين وشمال جالس بيطلقها بس كيف راح
يتعامل الان مع الصاروخ اللي ضربه هو
بموضوع الاستفتاء هذا خلونا نتناقش مع
ضيفنا المحرر التقني في اندبندنت عربيه
عبد الله السبع اهلا فيك معنا عبد الله
خلينا نبتدي من موضوع الاستفتاء على
بقاءه وفي رئاسه تويتر من عدمه صوت في ال-
همم الاستفتاء
الى الان مصر
ايه الناس اللي يصلون انا معهم فيه انا
انا صورت انه لا خليه يبقى في تويتر طيب
قول لي يعني معقول احد يعمل استفتاء على
نفسه ويخسر بدشكل طيب
الموضوع من الاساس يقال وفي مصادر كثيره
تكلمت عن هذا الموضوع ان هدفهم من هذا
التصويت انه يكون امرين اذا اذا تنحف هو
بطلب من مستثمريه تسلم لانهم قاعدين
يشوفون حاليا انه رئاسه تويتر رجعت تاثر
بشكل جدا كبير على مستقبل ايه زي ما
تلاحظون في الايام الماضيه خف همم على
قولتهم همم بروز تسلم في العالم بشكل كامل
اسهمها يعني في الفتره الماضيه من بعد
استحواذ الى ماسك على تويتر بشكل مباشر
فلذلك مستثمرين
يرجونا الاسلام
يرجع يقود تسلم مره ثانيه بنفسها حتى ممتع
الواحد عليها بخصوص تويتر او قياده
التويتر وموضوع فشل في حال ان نجح وهو
يثبت العالم سياسات الناجحه في الموضوع هو
سلاح ذو حدين فشل قال لهم انا اساسا مطلوب
مني اني اروح اكل تسلا وان نجح قال لهم
انتم اللي اخترتوني يلا خلاص انا مستمر
لكن حتى لو همم تنازل او تنهى كادت تويتر
اراء وطلبات راح تكون منفذه بحكم انه هو
المالك همم الوحيد لمن هذه المنصه فلذلك
همم حتى لو كان رئيس مجلس اداره
مختلفه اكيد راح يكون قرارات لها تاثير
مباشره
ينفذ كل طلباته بس لما يصير شيء يزعل
الناس يقول لهم بس هذا الرئيس حق تويتر
قد يضع دميه هي اللي تتوقع على قولتهم
الضرب على اي قرار فلا وصلت لتويتر قرار
يكون فيه رئيس ياخذ الضرب وكاله هو يطلع
في صيغه الموطن وينقذ الناس من قرارات هذا
الرئيس ما اتوقع ان سياسه قد تكون ناجحه
من قبل الاماس اضع شخص ياخذ الضرب ياخذ كل
شيء وبعدين قرار انا اطلع زي ما صار امس
يوم نزل القرار ايقاف
الترويج اللي من الصوت
انه يوقف
السياسه هذه
السياسه بشكل ذكي يبدو انه الان استوعب
انه لازم يلعب ويسوي حركات اكثر بس على
سيره هذه الموضوع اللي قلته حق الروابط
ومن روابط يعني ايش يكون صار يعني ايش
يكون خطر على بالهم انه يمنعوا اي شيء
منصات الثانيه
تويتر
انستغرام
[موسيقى]
فيديو حطيت رابط انستغرام تلقاهم يقللون
من ظهور المقطع
انه يحذفوا
هم كل من الاصوات التواصل بطريقه اخرى
تحارب الترويجي من الصوت ثانيه فلذلك شيء
طبيعي انه تويتر تصدر مثل هذا القرار
وتوقع ان التويتر قاعد تقول انتم
الانستغرام وسناب شات تمنعوني منين انكم
موجود عندكم حتى انا راح اسمعكم في المثل
وهو امر طبيعي يتوقع ولا هو شيء في مشكله
جدا كبيره خليني اخذك عبد الله الموضوع
الثاني اللي هو تحدثنا عنه حتى انا وانت
وكنا تكلمنا انه في مشكله كمان اخطر جلسه
بتواجه تويتر يبدو انها مشكله تقنيه او في
مشكله انه بتخرج الناس وما بيقدر يرجعوا
يدخلوا ثاني على حساباتهم اذا تشرح لنا
ايش اللي بيصير ايش سببها
اللي صار الايام الماضيه في تويتر مشكله
جدا مزعجه خاصيه التحقق بخطوتين توقفت
بشكل كامل في السعوديه وفي بعض الدول حول
العالم اي شخص رابط حساب رقم جواله ومفعل
خاصيه التحقق بخطوتين ما راح يقدر يدخل
على حساب نهائيا لذلك ضروري ضروري انك انت
ما تسوي تسجيل
تويتر اذا انت مفعل خاصيه التحقق بخطوتين
لانه قد ما تستطيع انك تعود للمراه نهائيا
اذا انت قادر توصل لحسابك وقادر
انك توقف خاصيه التحقق بخطوتين عن طريق
الجوال وتعتمد على التطبيقات مثل جوجل انت
تويتر مايكروسوفت انترنت الميزه اللي
بتاعه حجه الايفون ان انت تقدر تربط
الحساب
فيديو هيك اللي انت نشرته كنت بك كمان
بتحكي فيه عن هذه المشكله بس يعني انه طيب
اكيد الناس كتبت لتويتر على هذا الموضوع
هل كان عندهم رد هل كان في تبرير
تويتر
اي شخص حاليا
في خيار في الاعدادات وواجه مشكله في
الدخول همم بنفس الاعدادات هذه بامك يقدم
طلب
او كود التحقق بخطوتين ما يصلى والتويتر
خلال همم فتره اقل من اسبوع رحلوا
يساعدوني همم يخلونا يدخل مره ثانيه على
حساب اوكي بس هذا الحين ممكن الناس يقول
لك انه يربطوا مع مسك والجنان اللي جالس
بيصير في تويتر وفي نفس الوقت يقول لك لا
هذا الشيء كل الشركات ممكن تعاني منه
كل الشركات انستغرام
الى مميزات كثيره صارت عندهم مشاكل تقنيه
وهذا كان متوقع طبيعي مع تسارع في
الملصق انه بيقول همم المشتركين زادوا
معه في التغير وشغلات جدا كثيره هذه في
ملاحظ صراحه في الفتره الماضيه دائما
الشغلات الجدليه اللي يكون فيها جدال ايوه
بس تكون فلا اتوقع اكثر شيء او اكثر شيء
صار لتويتر لما ترامب لانهم هم اللي
ساهموا في نهضه من السمره ثانيه
بالمتابعين كمان هو يعني احنا بنشكرك على
هذه المداخله كان معناها المحرر التقني في
انتفاخ عند العربيه عبد الله السبع
المشاهدين انا اعيد القاكم غدا ان شاء
الله في حلقه جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]